Hey aim the game for the fame
everybody just on my name steady hands
always no track never going back always
being best you know got my man hold up
hold up this is what it would look like
if a virus Hey aim the game for the fame
everybody just on my name steady hands
always no track never going back always
been next you know got the man did he
say everybody jizz on my name everybody
just on my name you know this is why we
will bounce to anything else on a
chalkboard and these browser black look
at my rhythm wait I want you guys to
comment and let us know exactly at which
point you guys checked out due to cringe
I wanted I want to see a timestamp with
exactly when you guys alike
how would I subscribe your lives now
humble to be continued and not important
say dry humble well that's my time stamp
like why don't you lying why you always
lying oh my god
stop him lagging everything about this
dude screams what single lonely my
name's Christian I go to see vu I've
ever said my name is Marcus I'm doing
part-time school and then part-time work
I'm my name Caitlin I'm working
full-time and it's amazing my name is
Kiana I'm from Queens New York and I
produce a model I'm Wesley I just
graduated from UCSB
my name is Jalen I'm music producer
rapper three of them are gonna do well
the other three are gonna struggle yeah
pink Queens we're gonna do well yeah
yeah I don't think winds gonna do well
have you seen his height yeah they're
not winning in this group though not
saying that's what is this early but
that's how it's gonna be at picked up
yeah here's the thing he raised his hand
hyper grace he raised his hand
Wow so dudes are not feeling well
one-minute sense update older right yeah
yeah yeah so you said 18 delimit yeah
you should talk about em Rebecca Rebecca
nice to see ya sup guys so I guess style
I'm from New York I like your style
maybe that's a joke everybody's wearing
white shirt and avid jeans like I like
your style what I'm worried you can like
lick your elbow it could actually save
you from elimination
I only practice on a private
relationship fine impossible challenge
you want a few girls lichbane Carbon
power I'm gonna make these girls lick
pain if you let your elbow girls you're
gonna be able to it's gonna see who Lily
who wants it in fact in that ugly got
trying to do this stuff can if you can
like lick your elbow I only practice on
a private op that's pretty much it next
question I see good at playing lacrosse
yeah I played the cross ah so oh sweet
okay do you still play I played at UCSB
okay so we shouldn't probably ever play
together I mean that's dummy pretty fun
he was not interested what he ain't got
no options when you're five seven and
you're beside a guy who's six three a
reality sets in what's your guy's
deepest darkest secrets what's your
deepest darkest see how fans de but the
leading people Wow
men orange what
well that's deep I was not insightful
that was just creepy discreet but just
say you think you're attractive and you
want it with your head speaks are you
imagine if you were just stuck with one
person and you still limited them it's
not that I have better options I just
rather big nose like all right
yeah I like none of you anyway so what
are three words to describe you
I say shy introvert the earlier was the
short version now we're gonna see a full
song yes
Hey aim the game for the fame everybody
just know my name steady hands always no
track never going back
always being best you know got the man
they just put that again to make
you suffer
Wow okay the girl that just be boxed
he's gonna live later w where's your
have to do this over holy
the girl beatbox
good you should go
it's not that I'm good at it I just you
eliminate the least attractive person
[Music]
okay my birthday's coming up
any plans no not right now party
favorite dance move passe the walk you
show us know I'm biased because of all
those years dancing you know when people
ask you to dance
I hate one form I ask me to dance
okay you show me a move I don't think
you guys understand the mental fortitude
it requires to make it through these
videos aspired you to be a rapper
it was Linkin Park Chester no way yeah
huge Linkin Park that the person that's
pardon to rap dude from Lincoln Park I
try so hard yeah that isn't right you
notice that the pretty girls aren't
talking at all because they know they
don't have to talk they just gotta stand
there and look pretty and they're gonna
make it through the next round
the only people asking questions are the
ugly brats and it seems like a good job
so is that like I don't know you could
be so low energy that's your negative
energy I'm watching this guy talking I
just feel like the sun's getting further
away from the earth sorry I'm sorry
didn't tell me what that tattoo is about
though you know what the good boys
yes sir even the Jubilee producers like
yo you made us listen to you rap move it
on what do you call yourself like I just
take in any way take music yeah I like
doing different stuff like what like in
what genre of fights what do you I would
say music you guys have to fight to the
death right now that's what I'm talking
about on a guild we do not betray people
guys read up on this right I would say a
lot of Drake baby
[Music]
you asked me a question I'm sorry I love
you though I love you go you know that
boy mo he knows what he's doing I want
to appreciate something real quick
that's how easy yeah and he was like
she's a big girl
act like it's hard yes shoot saw that
okay that's a very subtle thing but it's
like I'm gonna reject you but I'm gonna
make it my fault yeah that I'm rejecting
you so you don't feel bad about yourself
and I can maintain and not you with me
yeah it's called a hook that's not you
it's me
can you eat sushi like one time I can
you see I had sushi sushi every single
day that's issues you see yesterday
[Music]
that's meeting you too it's always the
talking
[Music]
it was pretty like natural conversation
and have a lot in common so it was fun
yeah he's not interested but he ain't
gotten watches you you're not interested
yeah I'm starting to really respect
Jubilee because the way they edit this
they know exactly what they're doing
yeah I'm gonna start giving them a bit
of credit because this is where we got
to talking got to know each other Green
Carmen
yeah it's odd but I guess it's fun I had
a good time it's kind of creepy it's
kinda great it's a little eerie like no
one is like awesome it like this thirty
people watching us think yeah I'm
interested yeah I think we would yeah I
think I would have you done dad
I'm actually down to yeah she seems
smart so like I could learn a lot from
her
well the girl who talks the least during
the whole experience she seems smart
just say you wanna bust on her face just
say that it's all good hey girl you got
some yoga pants on you flexible watch
reflexes let's do this okay this is just
more evidence of what I said before if
you tall if you're attractive it's easy
mode but it is what it is when I was
young it was like that you know I
benefit from being six feet tall but I
remember like I'd go with my brother
he's six to better looking than I am
clean up because when you're young all
they have is looks they don't care if
you got a place or that stuff right as
we got older you know I'm saying I
picked up the slack you know more than
you no not anymore
I'm saying let the official your brother
and wise that's not gonna happen
we keep that the social medias will
never find it he's gonna most research
thing oh yeah Abbas brother on Google
search
ever I was brother never gonna find it
I've done a pretty good job keeping all
that offline yeah I don't know they
found some really cringe candidates like
at 18 I felt like I had better
personalities in them no playing with
the game in my name then I got a girl
just in my name look at park is the best
thing they're the same yeah do we know
what they're doing so tell us about what
you guys think how much did you cringe
we want to hear your thoughts why don't
you leave are you even Philly are you
still here they're still here if you're
still here if you are thank you that was
it for today's cringe report we want to
hear your comments below
[Music]